[Musica]
quando sono stata chiamata per fare
questo piccolo racconto della mia vita
mi è subito venuto in mente quando a 14
anni facevo la strada letteralmente di
corsa ma la casa mia barletta piazza
roma per arrivare al palazzetto dello
sport li facevo allineamento prima il
basket poi abbiamo sotto le gradinate
per fare i compiti e poi dopo facevo
altre due ore di pallavolo
come se non bastasse sabato e la
domenica andavo al circolo tennis sempre
barletta per continuare a giocare ero
afflitta da una specie di gioia da iper
cinesi sportiva
in realtà poi ho capito che era già il
mio primo modo di metterli alla prova
nei miei sogni e in tutto quello che è
possibile ed è proprio quello che sarà
il filo di questi dieci minuti insieme a
me quando sono cresciuta ho capito che
non sarei diventata martina navratilova
o manuela benelli o monica bastiani nel
basket eppure avevo trascorso quel
periodo della mia vita sportiva credendo
fermamente che avrei potuto diventare un
atleta così forte
mi sono chiesta dopo se tutta questa
voglia questa dedizione fosse stata
sarah ma non ve lo dico adesso se sono
convinta che questa dedizione smisurata
sia stata sala oppure lo voglia
proseguire il mio racconto e passò a
un'altra fase della mia vita quella in
cui smessa l'attività da atleta che è
durata ben 16 anni cominciò organizzare
eventi e lo faccio con una squadra di
donne in realtà una squadra di carissimi
amiche e va ceccatelli malessere il
cielo con manu benelli sarà la scuola di
sabrina catalani alessandra tanto voluto
nominare preso parte della mia vita con
loro comincio organizzare degli eventi
dal più piccolo poi man mano sempre più
grandi se primi grandi sempre più grandi
abbiamo realizzato anche due finali
scudetto sulla spiaggia di barletta ma
anche a ravenna oppure il world grand
prix di pallavolo femminile finali nel
palasport di andria con quasi 7 mila
persone la squadra di lavoro era sempre
la stessa questo gruppo affiatatissimo
ed incredibile di donne che erano
assolutamente non pagate ma che
lavoravano come delle professioniste
straordinari e in quel periodo
ricordando un po le cose come sono
andate come attraversavano la mente
ricordo che pensava ma nel 2020 erano 50
anni quindi può essere che organizzano
giochi olimpici
ancora una volta sognavo qualcosa di
incredibile che almeno finora non si è
verificato
continuando con la storia della mia
esperienza riesco a organizzare alcuni
eventi in cui coinvolgo delle grandi
atleti di varie discipline sportive
sempre col gruppo di incredibili amiche
e in uno di questi eventi a vietri sul
mare
ricordo che ci parliamo pranzo e ci
accorgiamo che tutte le grandi atlete
che avevamo a quel tavolo avevano subito
delle incredibili discriminazioni o
subivano delle discriminazioni
capiamo bene lo sport italiano c'era
qualcosa che davvero non andava e questo
qualcosa purtroppo danneggiava proprio
le donne
ricordo di aver passato due tre giornate
davvero d'inferno senza dormire sapendo
benissimo che fondare qualcosa che
avrebbe sollevato questo problema
avrebbe potuto cambiarmi la vita per
sempre il coraggio di fare questa cosa
me l'ha dato ancora una volta una
squadra formidabile
perché io sono andato in giro per
l'italia da bolzano bologna roma firenze
bari catania a parlare con le azzurre di
quel tempo quindi parliamo di una
ventina di anni fa ricordo tanti sguardi
bassi di ricordo tante diciamo volte in
cui la voglia di dirmi di si è
raffreddata dalla paura e probabilmente
dal sentire dentro di sé il fatto che un
prezzo ci sarebbe stato a quel sì io non
mi arresi non grazie soltanto la mia
incoscienza ma perché donne come monica
vaillant della nazionale di pallanuoto
patrizia panico o carolina morace del
mondo del calcio e le altre donne che ho
incontrato in testa ci metto la mia
sorella strale antonella bellutti e il
grande mito joseph all'inter
tutte queste donne mi dicevano luisa
andiamo avanti facciamolo e infatti
abbiamo costituito questa associazione
che ha cominciato a tirar fuori una cosa
mai fatta una serie di problemi a volte
ben radicati nella società italiana e
corrispondente a quel patriarcato duro a
morire a volte che facevano proprio
parte del sistema sportivo e cominciamo
a denunciare la cosa che ci è successo e
che succede probabilmente a molti di
quelli che avviano una battaglia su
qualcosa che non è ancora conosciuto e
che all'inizio veniamo bellamente
ignorate noi con i nostri rotoli di fax
scrivevamo praticamente a tutti
mandavamo lettere alle segreterie dei
ministeri alle federazioni delle
associazioni sportive ma soprattutto i
giornali e quando non possono più
ignorare c
cominciano a definirsi un po io mi
ricordo benissimo quando entravo nelle
riunioni si davano di gomito per dire
ecco adesso arriva all impazzata
femminista me lo ricordo molto bene ma
questa cosa sicuramente non mi ha
fermata siamo andati avanti abbiamo
ottenuto dei risultati che non sono
stati forse eclatanti ma hanno
cominciato a smantellare qualcosa che
non era giusto rimanesse così mi ricordo
proprio alla battaglia la prima grande
del setterosa le ragazze della
pallanuoto femminile trovano un coraggio
incredibile e denuncia insieme ad assist
che i loro premi
i campionati del mondo i campionati
europei era esattamente la metà di
quello degli uomini riescono a fare in
modo riusciamo a fare in modo che questi
premi vengano pareggiati aprono un
terreno enorme perché lo sport italiano
riconosca come fa ora che per le
competizioni internazionali e nazionali
non vi sia per i podi alcuna differenza
tra uomini e donne
riusciamo a tenere nel 2007 che il coni
inserisca tra i principi fondamentali la
tutela per la maternità delle atlete ed
è un altro grandissimo risultato perché
nelle scritture private che le atlete a
tutt'oggi scrivono che fanno con i loro
datori di lavoro che sono le società
sportive spesso c'era nero su bianco che
andavano a casa si era incinta noi
denunciavamo che quella era una vergogna
e abbiamo subito più di una minaccia e
abbiamo anche dovuto rispondere delle
querele vinte io credo che l'altro
risultato importante sia proprio
recentissimo direi degli ultimi cinque
anni forse una visibilità enorme del
fatto che le donne in italia non hanno
accesso a una legge dello stato è una
cosa assurda
succede con la legge 91 del 1981
proprio sul professionismo sportivo e
capita perché questa legge ha un
pezzetto che lascia ancora al movimento
sportivo in realtà coni e federazione il
compito di decidere quali siano le
discipline che devono essere
professionistiche che possono esserlo
quindi avvalendosi di diritti e che
quindi possono utilizzare questa legge
dello stato
beh voi non ci crederete ma nessuna
donna in italia può accedere a quella
legge
sono tutte dilettanti secondo lo stato
italiano anche la più titolata delle
nostre campionesse fa lo sport per
diretto la grande visibilità che abbiamo
ottenuto con altre campagne tipo azzurre
su raiuno ha portato per esempio le
ragazze del calcio non solo permetto di
assist naturalmente ma anche per il
nostro contributo arrivare finalmente su
raiuno in quel mondiale dove proprio gli
uomini non si sono qualificati
le atlete d'italia
le donne dello sposo italia che sono
anche allenatrici preparatrice e poche
dirigenti purtroppo riescono finalmente
a diventare visibili e dire ai suoi fan
un grande problema è questo problema va
risolto perché riguarda i diritti
fondamentali delle persone soprattutto
quelle che fanno un lavoro come l'ho
fatto io per quasi 16 anni e questo
lavoro è semplicemente invisibile con
assist abbiamo diciamo una piccola perla
che voglio ricordare nel 2018
recentissima veniamo convocati al tavolo
del ministero del lavoro proprio per la
riforma della legge 91 e mi viene ancora
un po di emozione ha ricordato per
questo tavolo enorme aveva lì al toro
tutto il gotha dello sport italiano
tutti i protagonisti più importanti
dello sport quindi le federazioni le
grandi associazioni e poi ce l'avevamo
noi e in mente quel giorno mi è venuto
questo gruppo di donne che mandare un
fax e che tentava di dire al mondo che
le donne erano discriminate in quella
giornata quel tavolo ad assist nel
chiesto di aprire quella riunione venne
chiesto di indicare la strada ed è stata
una grande emozione
non una strada che ovviamente abbiamo
percorso completamente anzi siamo solo
all'inizio però fu veramente
simbolicamente importante che una
piccola realtà come la nostra poteva
dire ai grandi che tipo di sguardo
bisognava per e dello sport
e allora vado alla conclusione del mio
ragionamento perché il mio obiettivo di
oggi è proprio far sì che le donne mi
guardino un attimo negli occhi e gli
uomini ascoltino
io credo che sia chiaro a tutti che
questo pianeta in questo momento ha
bisogno di una leadership femminile ha
bisogno della leadership di donne che
sanno riportare la visione del mondo ha
una visione collettiva ha una visione
che non è fatta di uomini o di donne
forti che non è fatta di suprematismo ed
i nazionalismi che è fatta di un modo di
vedere la vita che riguarda tutte e
tutti esseri umani e pianeta
insieme noi siamo chiamati a dare questo
sguardo kamala harris non è una marziana
e una di noi e lo dice benissimo
cristina comencini che proprio un po di
tempo fa quasi dieci anni fa nel teatro
curci di barletta faceva una lezione
bellissima di femminismo di vita
cristina comencini scriveva qualche
giorno fa
le donne hanno le caratteristiche per
guidare la cosa pubblica per guidare la
politica
abbiamo un talento straordinario care
amiche e cari ragazze care donne che
ascoltate che volete anche fare qualcosa
nel vostro piccolo così come nel mio
piccolo cerco di farlo io
non dobbiamo avere il coraggio di
guidare le nostre città di guidare le
nostre regioni di guidare lo stato di
essere presenti nelle grandi aziende di
non essere un elemento residuale che
viene lasciato guarda caso spesso le
donne quando sono le ancelle del
patriarcato o sono le regine della
cooptazione ecco non parlo di queste
donne
io voglio che voi troviate il coraggio e
ce lo diamo a vicenda perché con
compagni di squadra e compagni di
squadra come quelli che ha avuto io
quando organizzava gli eventi o quando
ho costituito l'associazione atlete e
continua a fare attivismo e questo il
modo di poter riuscire a trovare il
coraggio di esserci e noi abbiamo
bisogno davvero di dare uno sguardo
nuovo a tutto il mondo lo stanno facendo
in qualunque parte del pianeta
dobbiamo restare uniti e dobbiamo
tenerci accanto agli uomini che con noi
sanno benissimo il valore di questa
battaglia che non sposterà da un
suprematismo di genere a un altro ma ci
farà stare insieme finalmente alla pari
e finalmente
tutti senza paura